we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
here's an interesting question about the
words we use
to describe people who do certain things
in society in this case specifically the
sort of cue trumpist people
take a listen to this yeah i'm just
wondering
why trump and all these people that are
following him
and following you aren't considered
terrorists
um if it was the foreigners that came
with that attitude would be
um locking them up you know but
these it's supposed to be um terrorism
within the country too
as far as who it is that shouldn't make
any difference
terrorism is terrorism right these guys
are terrorizing this country
the republicans and not all of them but
those that are following trump
and the ones following q and q anon
and trump and his family that's
terrorism
we need to stop those people i wish they
just lock them up
it's the best place for them yeah well
so listen unless they actually commit a
crime
and many of these people have not or at
least not one that we're aware of you
can't just lock people up in that sense
but i think
that there's a really good point here
which is if
foreigners came to the u.s and did a
bunch of the things
that the seditionist the seditious
uh writers and q people and
pro-coup people were doing and saying uh
we would be saying look at what these
people are bringing from outside they're
coming in and they're
advocating for the overthrow of the
government i think we would be
obviously referring to them as
terrorists if that's the case
instead when it's what we have which is
you know mostly
white trump supporting men um
they're called militia or they're called
patriots
or they're called constitutionalists or
they're referred to as whatever the hell
they are
referred to and i think that you know to
some degree
we don't want to overstate the
importance of language
i've in certain cases including when it
comes to
we've talked about latinx as a
replacement for
latino or some of these other things
i've pointed out i think this is a
counterproductive focus on
the language but when the language
is directly reflective
of a political movement's priorities
which is we call
certain people militia and we call
certain people lone wolves and we call
certain people terrorists
uh we call certain people immigrants but
some are just called expats right we've
talked about these things before
it's not about let's change the language
because that will solve the problem
necessarily but let's understand the way
in which the language is being used to
propagate a false
image of what these folks represent in
society and in that sense i think that
the voicemail caller makes a very very
good point
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today i have to tell you we will be
talking about
i guess to inspire confidence in uh
i think it's blue origin is the name of
the the company
jeff bezos amazon founder is going to be
going to space on the first
commer passenger flight for a few
minutes we're going to talk about that
on today's bonus show
we will also talk about a u.s funded
study of wales
hearing that is going to go forward
despite concerns for the whale's health
what is going on here and what is being
done uh very interesting
story and and i've read a bunch of
interesting stuff about it we'll talk
about that on today's bonus show
and also remember that coveted
whistleblower from florida rebecca jones
um who was fired after trying to publish
the real covet data to the dashboard of
florida
she is now running against beleaguered
republican congressman matt gates and i
think that there's a lot of interesting
stuff going on they're including some
new revelations actually
about the circumstances of rebecca jones
firing so we're going to talk about all
of that on today's bonus show
how do you get access to the bonus show
it really couldn't be easier
just sign up at joinpakman.com that's it
you go to joinpackman.com
and you get a membership you can use the
coupon code better21 if you would like
to get a discount and if you prefer
if you already have an account with or
prefer to access the bonus show via
patreon you can do that as well
by going to patreon.com slash
david pakman show either will give you
access
within mere moments to the bonus show
and also remember make sure you're
subscribed to the new youtube channel we
have a
second youtube channel now called pacman
live
people are going crazy i've seen people
threaten to burn down their own
homes in a panic over how crazy this
bonus this new channel is
you can find it at uh davidpakman.com
slash pacman live we will see you on
today's bonus show
or otherwise on tomorrow's program
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman